whatever you think of star wars  battlefront multiplayer centric design  it's hard to deny that the game looks  and sounds great capturing much of the  auditory magic of Star Wars it's also  home to more than a few subtle  references to the movies the best of  which was only just discovered as found  by GamesRadar a short cut scene setting  up the Empire's goal in Walker assaults  he's a stormtrooper watching a hologram  message inside of a hangar in the  background a pair of stormtroopers can  be seen walking around when one slams  his head into the stairs in front of it  that seems like a clear reference to the  classic blooper from Star Wars a new  hope where a stormtrooper bumps his head  into a door after it opens a nice vine  GamesRadar for more star wars  battlefront and Star Wars Episode 7 news  stay tuned to gamespot